as every beer commercial ever has
pointed out friends make life better and
that's even truer when you want to watch
certain movies because you need someone
to scream with someone to grab drawing
the scary parts and someone to call at
all hours when nightmares wake you up in
a cold sweat so find a friend and gather
your loved ones clothes because here's a
look at some movies you should never
watch alone of the Ring despite the
decidedly dated piece of technology at
its center this movie about a haunted
videotape has actually become more
acutely unsettling since its release
more than a decade ago but then you'd
have deliberately put the tape in your
VCR and press play
but since the advent of digital media
you could end up watching the whole of
curse at horrifying thing on the
internet before you knew what hit you
it's a wreck roll that ends in death
plus if you watch the ring you have also
by definition seen that video so
[Music]
the descent down we go further into the
rabbit hole of blood shilling terror
with the aptly titled adventure horror
the descent it tells a tale of a few
adventurous younger women gearing up for
a spelunking trip in the Appalachian
Mountains of North Carolina but
everything goes sour when they drop into
the cave with no way out
bathed in pitch-black darkness and
surrounded by warped humanoid creatures
known as crawlers that's are hungry for
flesh and blood
the women are forced to fight their way
out of the hole and just like a cave
expedition watching the descent is
something you should never do alone the
woman in black Daniel Radcliffe plays a
baby-faced barrister who uncovers a
sinister secret in this historical
horror movie the whole thing features a
creepy gothic mansion an old-school
grudge and a vengeful ghost with an
uncanny gift for convincing children to
kill themselves so you know not really
something you should check out by your
lonesome there's nothing like a good
old-fashioned haunted house story to
give you the heebie-jeebies when you
watch it by yourself but the woman in
black raises the stakes by imbuing every
creaking door every warping floorboard
and every ordinary household object with
a sense of freaky foreboding even if you
don't end up spotting the femme fatale
from the title than a Victorian veil
lurking in a corner the shadowy walk
through your dark house after watching
it is one that you won't be able to make
solo the babadook written and directed
by Aussie Triple Threat Jennifer Kent in
a directorial debut the babadook centers
around the mother and her son stalked by
the creepy thing in the movies title a
pop-up monster book named mr. Baba Dook
who threatens multiple murders of anyone
denies his existence if you're a really
clever one and you know what it is to
see then you can make friends with a
special one a friend of you and me
following a series of febrile seizures
violent Tolosa nations insomnia induce
two blackouts and acts of physical
aggression all caused by the babadook
amelia and sam tried valiantly to
vanquish the Beast once and for all one
of the scariest films in recent memory
the babadook isn't one to catch a lone
don't breathe an opportunistic break-in
goes terribly wrong in this film by fede
alvarez as a trio of small-time team
crooks try to burgle a blind man who
turns out not to be quite as easy a
target as he originally appeared the
tables turn almost instantly leaving the
would-be thieves trapped in the dark
unfamiliar house where a misstep or
cough could bring their death and
Alvarez keeps attention at an unceasing
fever pitch for the full duration of the
movie poltergeist more than three
decades after its original release
poltergeist distiller who's who of
terrifying tropes ghosts reaching out
through the scrambled signals on your TV
man eating trees lurking outside your
window evil clowns hiding under your bed
and a portal to another dimension
casually stuffed into the closet and no
matter how long it's been since you
first saw it
poltergeist still makes even the most
cookie-cutter suburban tract house feel
like it might be full of otherworldly
threats without a friend by your side
you'll be too creeped out to continue on
it follows the acclaimed horror darling
it follows has sparked a new wave of
smartly scary flicks and understandably
so as it's a film unlike any other in
its genre directed by David Robert
Mitchell this movie takes the teen
slasher genre and completely inverts it
replacing gore with an overwhelming
constant sense of dread and impending
doom while slightly commenting on the
whole sex will get you killed message in
so many traditional teen murder
thrillers
it follows strings you along leaving you
sweaty and skeptical but wholly
satisfied and will follow you long after
its final scene Antichrist Charlotte
Gainsbourg and Willem Dafoe's star in
this experimental horror flick which
divided both fans and critics thanks to
its twisted narrative obscure plots and
viscerally disturbing sexual content
entered on a couple grieving the death
of their son the movie starts out with a
graphic sex scene and delves into some
serious dark places as it explores
themes of motherhood misogyny and sexual
violence not for everyone or maybe
anyone and are certainly not to be
watched alone
deliverance a bromantic river rafting
trip turns into an all-out of
life-ruining night
classic from 1972 starring Jon Voight
and Burt Reynolds back in their heyday
as chiselled leading men deliverance was
a multiple Oscar nominee the year it was
released which makes it a damn fine
movie by all accounts but thanks to that
scene film bus you know the one
it makes for damned uncomfortable
viewing like a trip down the Kahoolawe
huazi River the narrative journey of
deliverance has one better taken with a
few close friends The Human Centipede
there may never be another body horror
film is thoroughly utterly repulsive as
a human centipede except maybe the Human
Centipede sequels which are just like
the human centipede
but somehow grosser in this first entry
in the series a demented scientist
kidnaps three people and surgically
attaches them mouth to but to create the
human centipede from the title a
procedure halted in the movies
promotional materials as 100% medically
accurate despite a broad consensus that
a human centipede is profoundly
disgusting and lacking in all respects
except a unique premise it still rates a
decently with critics but much like its
central monstrous surgical creation this
movie just doesn't work as a solo
undertaking lake mungo this underrated
aussie horror flick is a suspenseful
slow burn from start to finish as it
tells the story of a family consumed by
grief in the wake of their teenage
daughter's death it's sharp documentary
style and with lots of creepy tension
stemming from barely glimpsing threats
of unseen things like go bump in the
night lake mungo spends nearly every one
of its 89 minutes building to an
incredibly freaky climax that'll scare
you half to death
while also leaving you with many many
more questions than answers
hard candy before she earned raves for
playing juno macguff or walked through
walls as Kitty Pryde in the x-men Ellen
Page cut her teeth on a very different
kind of role back in 2006 Paige played
the sadistic iron-hearted Hayley Stark
in hard candy a 14 year old who has
victim written all over her at the start
of the film
Haley quickly turns a table on Jeff the
32 year old photographer and probable
predator she met on the internet after
inviting herself to his home she drugs
him and tortures him in a series of
brutal scenes that seem to go on forever
between its killer suspense and dark
subject matter hard candy
a comfortable viewing experience but
it's ever so slightly more bearable if
you have a companion to share the bad
vibes unfriended if ever there was a
movie best to watch with half a dozen of
your closest pals
its unfriended six teenagers on a group
chat find themselves being picked up one
by one by an unseen scoped based entity
that might or might not be the ghosts of
their dead friend unfriended as an
original horror story for the social
media age and it's definitely meant to
be a group experience feeling extra bold
make it a virtual get together and watch
it with your besties on a Google hangout
and hope that nobody experiences any
technical difficulties green room if you
thought the other movies on this list
were intense you haven't seen anything
like green room an all-out raucous
horror picture framed around the dimly
lit hardcore punk show this film skirts
the edges of torture porn but spins
towards absurdity with elements
reminiscent of Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world zooming in on a keen portrayal of
what the punk subculture is all about
the band at the center of the story is
the ain't rights featuring the late
Anton Yelchin as the bassist Pat and
alia Shawkat on guitar as Sam they
opened their setlist with a cover of the
Dead Kennedys Nazi Punk's cough and a
later find the body of a girl backstage
realizing she'd been murdered the
members of the ain't right attempt to
notify authorities but are themselves
attacked by a group of neo-nazis led by
the chillingly evil Patrick Stewart of
all people if nothing else this is a
movie all about the value of doing your
research before making your setlist mama
what can compare to a mother's love well
that's exactly what the Guillermo del
Toro produced a movie mama aims to
answer starring in to Stella's Jessica
Chastain as the hesitant but
well-meaning Annabelle and Game of
Thrones Nikolaj coster-waldau in a
double role as a financially devastated
homicidal Jeffrey and his grief-stricken
twin brother Lucas this supernatural
flick delivers both a myth buried in
Maternity and a whole truckload of
scares from the shadowy figure that
lingers over Lucas's to ferrell younger
nieces to the final reveal that's
equally as haunting this film is
definitely one worth watching just you
know not alone
ex machina robots and red lights and
rebellion a true triple threat in the
world of sci-fi you've likely heard of
this Alex Garland helmed film or at
least seen Oscar Isaac donning a full
beard and tearing up the dance floor
don't be fooled by that unexpected
moment of humor though ex machina we've
sleek sci-fi with scathing psychological
horror warning of the possible dangers
of sentient artificial intelligence and
what can happen when you give humans
more power than they deserve garland
makes his directorial debut with this
film which also stars Isaac Star Wars
The Force awakens co-star domhnall
gleeson as well as the newest lara croft
olivia vikander but he wouldn't know
that a movie this good could be anyone's
first ex machina is sinister and spooky
spec it's a live fiction that feels
uncomfortably close to reality you'll
likely never look at a piece of
technology the same way again after
giving it a watch so it's best to have
someone by your side to remind you that
yes humans do still exist and no you
don't have to fear the toaster thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]